[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
everybody
[Music]
[Music]
so
him
uh
there you go
you can try it
[Music]
okay
everybody
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states and mrs trump
well thank you very much please and i
just want to congratulate everybody the
dow jones industrial average
just broke for the first time in history
thirty thousand
it's now uh that's good it's great for
jobs and it's good for everything
and this is the ninth time that we set a
record during the course of 2020 and
it's the 48th time that we've set the
record during the trump administration
and there's never been anything like
that so i just want to congratulate
everybody that worked so hard the white
house but
maybe most importantly the people of our
country it's a tremendous achievement
the first lady and i are thrilled to
welcome you all to the beautiful rose
garden where the first lady actually
worked
very hard on renovating it it was 61
years it was in rough shape
a very big job actually when you go to
the wires underground people have no
idea how complex it is but
uh you've done a fantastic job thank you
very much
[Applause]
and we're also very happy to have with
us my daughter ivanka
and jared and theodore arabella
joseph thank you very much for coming
they like
the turkey thank you very much
on behalf of the entire trump family i
want to wish every american a healthy
and very
happy thanksgiving we're here today to
continue a beloved annual tradition
the official presidential pardon of a
very very fortunate
turkey because thanksgiving is a special
day for turkeys i guess probably for the
most part not a very good one when you
think about it
the first turkey to dodge the white
house dinner table received unofficial
clemency
when president abraham lincoln's son
tad begged his father to spare his new
friend
for the past 73 years the national
turkey federation
has presented the national thanksgiving
turkey
to the president starting under
president george h.w
bush these birds have received a formal
pardon
every single year today is my honor to
present to you this year's lucky bird
corn and just in case we needed him
cobb corn and cop that's not too hard to
remember is it
these two magnificent gobblers were
selected from
the official presidential flock of 30
turkeys
some real beauties they were raised by
the chairman of the national turkey
federation himself
ron cardell ron thank you very much ron
please
stand up great job
ron thank you for being here and your
family beautiful family thank you very
much for being here appreciate it
like so many presidential flocks this
one started in the great state of iowa
in what can only be described as an act
of blatant pandering
and by the way i love the state of iowa
these two turkeys sought
to win the support of iowans across the
state by naming themselves corn and cobb
after today's ceremony these birds will
retire under the care of skilled
veterinarians
at iowa state university a tremendous
university
in ames once there people of all ages
will be able to visit them and learn
about
poultry science veterinary medicine and
the noble american tradition of farming
we
love our farmers i'll tell you
and we hope and we know that's going to
happen that corn and cobb
have a very long happy and memorable
life this year our nation commemorates
the 400th anniversary of the pilgrims
landing on plymouth rock
after arriving in the new world the
brave men and women of
the mayflower endured a bitter and
dangerous winter very very dangerous
with
many were sick most were starving and
all were praying for a miracle
thankfully god heard their prayers
from our earliest days america has
always been a story of
perseverance and triumph determination
and strength
loyalty and faith this week in a time
that is very unusual but in so many
ways very very good what we've
endured and been able to endure with the
vaccines now coming out one after
another it's an incredible thing that
happened
one of the greatest medical achievements
that this
planet has ever seen but it's time to
remember that we
live in a great great country the
greatest of them all
and there's nothing even close as far as
i'm concerned
every american can be united in
thanksgiving to god
for the incredible gifts he has bestowed
upon us the blessings of family
community and this
exceptional beautiful and great country
it's greater than ever before during
this thanksgiving we extend our eternal
gratitude to the doctors nurses
health care workers and scientists who
have waged the battle
against the china virus and we give
thanks for the vaccines and therapies
that will soon end
the pandemic it's just just such a
tremendous feeling to know that they're
coming and they'll be coming
probably starting next week or shortly
thereafter
we send our love to every member of the
armed forces
and the law enforcement heroes their
lives to keep america safe
to keep america great and as i say
america first
shouldn't go away from that america
first
[Applause]
we give thanks to the priceless freedoms
that we've inherited and
we ask god to watch over and protect
your nation
and its people during this incredible
holiday and
in all of the years to come we ask that
of god
once again melania and i wish to thank
everybody for your incredible courtesies
and also wish you a happy thanksgiving
and now it's time for the moment of our
guest of honor
they've been waiting and in this case
he's been waiting for this
and uh bring him out look at that
beautiful beautiful bird
oh so lucky that is a lucky bird
wow
i hereby grant you a full heart
thank
[Applause]
foreign
happy thanksgiving to everybody thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
a pardon for yourself mr president my
president
[Applause]
elected
[Applause]
you